hey what is up guys mkbhd here and we
are barely into 2016 and we're already
hearing all kinds of rumors of course
about the next iphone the iphone 7
uh wireless charging maybe
oled display possibly
waterproof technology maybe
no headphone jack
yeah no headphone jack in the iphone 7.
the three and a half millimeter audio
jack is one of the oldest i o ports
that's still around like you don't see
ethernet that much anymore you don't see
firewire anymore you don't see vga
anymore they used to be everywhere but
every single device that's come out in
the last couple years still has that
audio jack it's kind of like the
grandfather of legacy io all its older
relatives have died firewire is dead but
they've all been replaced by digital
ports so hdmi
thunderbolt usb type c
but everything still has that audio jack
the iphone has always been a struggle of
fitting as much stuff as possible and as
compact of a space as possible it's not
even really about thinness the ipod
touch is already like 10 thinner than
the iphone and it has an audio jack
still it's not about the thinness but
there's just so much stuff packed into
an iphone so this battle to fit more and
more stuff into the iphone every year
has of course come with its sacrifices
you probably all remember the 30 pin
connector that every ipod and iphone
user had eventually apple just decided
it's too big we want to fit more stuff
in the iphone so they switched to the
way smaller thunderbolt cable to replace
it it makes sense for apple but that in
typical apple fashion screws over
everyone who was using their previous
stuff so now your docs don't work your
battery cases don't work your chargers
don't work all those accessories that
plug into 30 pin don't work anymore but
that was just the sacrifice apple was
willing to make to fit more stuff now
you might not ever consider getting rid
of the three and a half millimeter audio
jack it's kind of a staple everything is
fine with it but when you consider how
much space it actually takes up inside
the chassis it actually takes up a lot
and it's a big port so at that level a
couple of millimeters can be pretty
important so apple's logical solution
seems to point to
iphone 7 just get rid of the audio jack
and if you still want to plug in
headphones you have to do that through
the lightning port now okay this seems
insane because it kind of is but at
least we can understand it a little from
apple's perspective and also there's
also like tiny advantages to using
lightning for audio because it's a
digital port so apple could toss in some
little software features here and there
into the os you could have minor things
like your music app opening the second
you plug your headphones in
and lightning headphones could talk back
to your iphone maybe setting a certain
eq as soon as they're plugged in you
could have noise cancelling headphones
that instead of using their own battery
taps into the iphone's power via
lightning kind of the same way the apple
pencil
taps into the ipad pro for battery so in
apple's mines it makes sense to just
kill off the big old auxiliary port and
do everything through lightning of
course in classic apple fashion this
again means temporarily screwing over
everyone because who has lightning
headphones looks like philips actually
makes a pair that you can buy right now
but they're 300 bucks so for everyone
who doesn't want to buy a new pair of
headphones apple will probably sell a
lightning to auxiliary adapter for oh i
don't know 50 bucks
classic want to keep using the awesome
pair of wired headphones that you
already have
adapter to play audio in your car that
doesn't have bluetooth
adapter want to charge your phone and
listen to headphones at the same time
unless there's two lightning ports in
the next iphone yeah adapter so this is
such an apple thing to do at this point
it doesn't actually really surprise me
at this point the iphone 7 is so far
into development that there's no point
in like arguing it it's probably already
set in stone it's gonna happen so at
this point all we really can do is brace
for it but also think about it people
got mad when apple got rid of the floppy
drives in the first imac but then we got
used to it people got mad when apple got
rid of the cd drive then we got used to
it people got mad when apple got rid of
firewire and their high-end machines
then we got used to it people got mad
when apple got rid of the 30 pin
connector in favor of lightning in the
iphone and then we got used to it so
people are going to get mad
if slash when apple gets rid of the
audio jack in their iphone
but
they'll get used to it if i had the
choice obviously i would have the next
iphone be a full three millimeters
thicker it would keep the audio jack it
would have a bigger battery it would
have bigger speakers etc but you know
that's not up to me and i'm not the only
one who thinks this too people plenty of
people have had this idea but there's
been this trend going towards thinner
phones and that's just the way apple
does things just kind of funny that the
company that brought us
the ipod might be the first to get rid
of
the audio jack something to think about
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace